[Musique]
mon père était chili et quand j'étais
petit je l'accompagnais dans son
laboratoire de chimie observer la magie
des réactions donc forcément tout
naturellement je me suis destine à être
chimiste jusqu'à ce que je perde
l'odorat dans après une intoxication au
monoxyde de carbone quand j'étais
étudiante j'ai perdu l'odorat pendant
quelques mois et quelques mois c'est
vraiment très long je ne sentais plus
l'odeur de la tasse de café et plus
aucune odeur l'alimentaire ne venez
stimuler mon appétit on appétit a
disparu je ne sentais plus d'odeurs de
fleurs plus d'odeurs d'alert plus de
souvenirs à l'improviste en croisant une
personne parfumé ma bulle n'avait plus
de saveur plus d'odeur bon j'ai eu de la
chance quand même heureusement j'ai
retrouvé l'odorat progressivement donc
les émotions sont arrivés en cascade le
bonheur tout simple qui va vous faire
sourire de sentir une fleur de troènes
fraîche et sensuelle solaire mis les
croquis une fraise juteuse verte fruité
à la fois l'odeur de mon cheval adoré et
bien sûr retrouver toutes ses fabuleuses
odeur de laboratoires de chili les
odeurs et leur pouvoir avait
révolutionné ma vie je suis donc entré à
dix cas alors on n'imaginait pas que
j'ai redoublé parce que j'y suis
toujours
je suis enseignante maintenant là bas
alors sachez qu'un professionnel de
l'olfaction memories plus de mille
odeurs différentes et vos capacités sont
les mêmes la différence résulte de
l'éducation un de mes étudiants a dit
zitka apprend 200 matières premières par
an et sept exercices répétitifs et
quotidien qui peut peut-être les lacets
accélère le processus qui transmet
l'information entre la mémoire et le
neocortex le néocortex et la zone du
raisonnement et c'est donc la zone du
langage
cet exercice améliore t-il la créativité
alors là franchement je manque
d'objectivité pour vous répondre
mais la recherche du beau du plaisir
du bien-être peut le laisser supposer
dans tous les cas cet exercice développe
notre sens et notre instinct autour des
sens justement et des émotions
l'odorat c'est notre sens le plus
primitif est ce que vous le saviez
il est le lien essentiel avec la mémoire
et avec les émotions
pourtant un neuroscientifique m'a dit un
jour que les odeurs n'existait pas c'est
embêtant ce qui existent sont les
molécules odorantes et volatil qui sont
capturés par notre nez et c'est le
cerveau qui fait le reste du travail qui
interprète le signal mais pourtant une
odeur un parfum c'est un souvenir et des
parfums sont de puissants magiciens qui
peuvent nous transporter au travers des
années que nous avons vécu c'est ce que
10 à helen keller est une auteur
américaine sourdes et aveugles
alors face à donner un petit exercice ce
soir vous avez une normalement elle
accueille ses petites bandelettes de
papier qui sont délicatement
harmonieusement parfumé fermer les yeux
comme ça on se verra pas du tout et vous
mettez la mouillette sous votre nez
alors est ce que vous êtes envahis de
plaisir ou autre chose
de toute façon une émotion et est ce que
on a réussi notre pari on vous a fait
voyager dans le temps
peut-être en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne maintenant vous savez que je
suis né où nos deux fois mais le parfum
lui
vous savez quand il est né mais il
trouve son origine dans l'antiquité du
latin perfume au travers la fumée il
transportait nos prières jusqu'au dieu
cet outil de communication entre les
hommes a traversé les siècles d'histoire
son rôle social apanage des puissants
bien sûr puis des riches évidemment on a
fait un objet de luxe que l'on cultive
encore aujourd'hui on le trouve partout
tellement son pouvoir et grands des
peintures murales en passant par les
voitures des gels douche bien loin de la
simple hygiène au déodorant corporelle
des parfums d'ambiance aux évidentes
parfums accessoires incontournables à
toute séduction c'est en recherche
permanente de plaisir
des motions constructive et vous
parfumer est un rituel positif notre
propre odeur qu'au départ nos gènes
notre stress et notre alimentation fait
de notre corps une usine remarquablement
puantes c'est pourquoi nous nous
parfumeront pour capturer un éventuel
partenaire le parfum que nous
choisissons dit aussi qui nous sommes il
signe la tribu à laquelle nous
appartenons et ils ciblent tel cupidon
celui qui sera sensible à ces effluves
de l'attirance incontrôlable corps a
suscité himmler à l'odeur des croissants
chauds il n'y a qu'un pas vous
conviendrez d'ailleurs que certains
parfums féminins n'est ce pas messieurs
sont à croquer de l'attirance suscitée
par une odeur ont fait un outil
marketing on appose une signature
olfactive à une enseigne commerciale
vous procurant ainsi un certain
bien-être
alors pourquoi partiriez vous vous
pouvez pas lutter vivre sans sentir
revient à vivre sans respirer vous est
manipulable
grâce à deux centimètres carrés de
muqueuses nasales situe en août vote
mais cette muqueuse nasale est à pied
c'est de quelques millions de neurones
récepteur vous n'êtes jamais promené
dans un centre commercial agréablement
parfumé en toute insouciance
vous n'avez jamais senti une enseigne
commerciale avec une identité olfactive
bien marquer avant même que vos yeux de
la voix mais cet usage peut permettre
aussi de gérer le stress et de manipuler
les foules notamment dans les transports
en commun et à tokyo
on diffuse une odeur de menthe poivrée
pour améliorer la productivité dans une
usine
alors êtes vous stresser etes-vous
fatigué et bien à chaque fois nous avons
une solution odorantes dans la mesure où
le système limbique contrôle à la fois
notre odorat et nos émotions il est
normal que certains parfums et le
pouvoir de détendre ou stimuler les sens
bien sûr je vous ai parlé d' usage
marketing mais au-delà de cet usage la
médecine
reste maintenant à l'ohl faction
pourquoi parce que notre odorat est en
lien direct avec notre mémoire sans
passer par l'analyse au préalable cela
permet de travailler la mémorisation par
exemple chez des patients cérébrolésés
donc les professionnels de l'olfaction
collabore désormais avec le corps
médical à garges par exemple l'odeur du
gaz ou du savon de marseille ou du
chocolat qui vous parlera quand même
mieux permet de travailler la
rééducation de patients souffrant de
trouble neurologique grave à la maison
des adolescents de paris à l'hôpital
cochin
c'est un autre avantage de l'odorat qui
est exploité c'est le lien direct avec
l'émotion la création d'un parfum
suscite énormément d'émotion de la peur
du plaisir de la joie de la découverte
est tout un monde d'émotions et de
perception qui sont désormais à la
portée des thérapeutes un nez
électronique par ailleurs sera bientôt
disponible pour détecter les pathologies
vasculaires et là une recherche
permanente de nourriture dans la journée
on est quand même bien placé pour le
savoir
permet de rythmer la vie des patients
atteints d'alzheimer et permet de
reculer l'atteinte de cette maladie chez
ces personnes
nous avons également le cas d'une
écossaise qui s'appelle joy mind qui
elle détecte olfactivement la maladie de
parkinson
vous voyez que l'odorat a encore
beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre
donc vous l'aurez compris on vous a
trouvé un partenaire on vous a procuré
du bien-être et maintenant si on vous
soigne et bien l'industrie de la
parfumerie relève le défi depuis déjà
plus de dix ans l'industrie de la
parfumerie c'est en europe plus de 700
parfum lancé par an c'est le quatrième
acteur économique français ce sont des
dizaines de molécules de synthèse sorti
de l'esprit des chimistes et ce sont
également des nouveaux gestes qui
améliore votre quotidien
comme par exemple le réveil olfactif ou
le sms
parfumer la parfumerie c'est un métier
passion et quand on a la passion
il n'y a rien d'impossible donc la
parfumerie relève tous les défis et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui le premier le plus
grand défi c'est de rendre sa place aux
odeurs toute leur place aux odeurs donc
du sens bon de notre enfance à la
détection des maladies du bien-être au
plaisir et bien les parfums vont
révolutionner votre vie alors êtes vous
prêt à vous abandonnez et à vous laisser
mener par le bout du nez
merci beaucoup